عين اتجاهًا جديدًا من الشركات
الأمريكية حيث يتزايد متغير دلتا في
جميع أنحاء البلاد ، الرئيس التنفيذي لمجموعة
يونيون سكوير للضيافة
، شركة المطعم داني ماير
، يريد
أن يتم تطعيم موظفيه وعملائه إذا كنت تريد حقًا عدم التطعيم ،
يمكنك أن تموت في مكان
آخر ويمكنك  اذهب أيضًا للعمل في مكان
آخر
كان ماير متقدمًا على قضايا الصحة العامة
قبل أن يحظر التدخين في
بعض مطاعمه في التسعينيات ، وقد
أدى ذلك
حقًا إلى المدينة ، حيث أخبرني المدير التنفيذي
لجمعية إدارة الموارد البشرية
جوني تايلور
أنه أخبرني معظم الموظفين  يريدون
تفويضات لقاح ،
هناك بعض المنظمات التي
تحاول خطوة واحدة أخرى قبل أن
تقول
إذا اخترت عدم التطعيم ،
فسيتعين عليك اختبار عدة مرات
خلال الأسبوع على الدايم
الخاص بك وسيتعين عليك ارتداء  قناع في
مكان العمل وليس أي قناع
ولكن هذا القناع الجراحي n95 أعني أننا سنقوم
في نهاية اليوم بجعل هذا الأمر غير مريح بعض الشيء
جدول
لك لأنك تجعله غير مريح
ومكان العمل أقل راحة
لزملائك ، عمالقة التكنولوجيا مثل facebook twitter
google ، يتخذون موقفًا بشأن اللقاحات ،
تتخذ Microsoft منهجًا
مختلفًا في الوقت الحالي ،
سيكون هناك مزيج من
اختبار اللقاحات
و  استثناءات لأنه
بمعنى ما إذا كنت تفكر في السياسات
التي يحتاجها المرء
يجب أن تستوعب أفضل الممارسات
الثلاثة